oh my god I've never your solid trailer
was so good I need to find somebody to
talk to about it but who yeah it's just
a box wait a second I knew us I knew it
Oh Lori's got me giant bomb mayonnaise
hate her Oh hosts of Metal Gear Scanlon
that's right takes my lunch breaks and
hang out in boxes ok actually room back
here don't talk about my gear solid oh
do I come on boy holds it give us put it
is kind of what they've been doing with
a the phantom pain it's just saying they
go 20 minutes of footage emergent
gameplay enjoy here's the thing with me
though is that Metal Gear has always
been story first and then gameplay
second really i like i love the gameplay
metal year and i always have but story
has always been the driving spokes
because i just suck at stealth games so
it's like I play those games mainly for
the story but this one specifically
especially after playing ground zeroes
and it's like oh this plays so much
better than any metal gear yeah seeing
it in action here for 20 minutes it
makes me way more excited than I already
was so it was kind of a weird pc
gameplay because it was obviously this
is from TGS it's got a bunch of dudes I
don't speak Japanese you speak German at
in the least no I mean hot yes Oh does
it yes yes yes yes yes the whole time
yeah so they were totally into it that
obvious and they said quiet a lot yeah
that's the name of the lady sniper it is
who apparently is your buddy I didn't
realize that yeah I didn't know she was
a villain from those initial trailers or
what but yeah she's on the Diamond Dogs
or whatever your crew is and when the
whole thing starts it kind of unlike all
the rest i guess it was very arid kind
of desert Afghanistan stuff yeah weird
this was kind of like I'm takes Snake
Eater on the Vita at the moment right
kind of like that more like tropical and
like setting I couldn't tell if it was
like South America or if it was like a
you know I'm type area or
where was but yeah like all the gameplay
septic shown so far has been in
Afghanistan and I've confirmed that that
is Afghan some in the desert stuff cuz
that's like going to save master Miller
or whatever with Ocelot so yeah I don't
know where specifically this is but it
looked very snake eatery every time they
shows where these gameplay clips they
show like a new like to keep you have
and the weird like emergent stuff that
comes from that like they what's the
Fulton recovery so looking at the
balloon yeah it's I'm sort of getting
used to how ridiculous that is now how
are you so it is I'm sure full military
like yeah that's what the US military's
been doing for years and he's just got
like balloons like falling out of the
package yeah every soldier when it
leaves the battlefield whatever lift it
up to a thing goats horses yeah but the
new one that the thing was Steve
inflatable snake thing yes and there's
the many ways in which you can use that
thing the because there's always been
stupid ways of distracting guards like
it started fairly simple with the well I
guess in the first one if you could
knock it's like okay that makes sense
mmm second one is where you can start
like throwing magazine like empty
magazine clips remember and then
actually i think it was in two as well
you could start using the porn yeah put
it down and just this inept guards just
like see you ladies like well I'm just
gonna be completely frozen the spot
until someone kills me yeah so yeah it's
gotten progressively stupider which I
also liked better in my mind the
inflatable snake is kind of amazing yeah
and he the first time he threw an out it
was like okay distracted her for a
little bit when he went to stop it and I
think it deflated I think I grew like
you awfully everyone say cheese like
three of them mmm and then another stage
she used it as a weapon Tanaka graphics
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] awesome look
great yes games I don't know it feels
very meta Gary which they're making some
big departures with the you know it's
open world and every yeah that's a huge
departure for the series but obviously
like that DNA of metal gear is still all
over the place because there's just
weird crap
like the bit where he I think he gets
cost he gets seen and he's pulling out
the the tranq gun yeah and then quiet
like knocks the dudes helmet off yeah so
he can get the life of one shot trying
to down the guy take that yeah yeah
birds awesome cool and also quiet like I
don't know are they are they trying to
say that she's like a cyborg or
something's like when she lands from the
parachute there was that huge like stomp
like she's like really heavy yeah and
then she like dashes off all crazy and
she's making all the desk hiccup and
like I there's gonna be some weird metal
gear like van type yeah superhuman
something going on yeah it's not like
the black outline stuff that keeps
happening I think she caught up with the
chopper at the end like ridiculously
fast as well it was already airborne by
the time yeah I gotta pop them on board
it as well yeah I get the sense she's
gonna be a major character I don't know
if you're gonna have other people that
like in the field or whatever helping
you know she seemed to be a pretty
integral part of the game yeah so maybe
I don't know if you'll have a whole
squad or what are you looking forward to
it yes it looks incredible like you
played ground zeroes right yeah and the
game plays way better than any metal
gear ever it is that's like like I
remember it's sort of almost suffering
through for things like the big boss
storyline has always been a little more
grounded than solid snake held snakes is
but like today's technology and all the
crazy Patriot stuff like snake eater was
kind of the most grounded and realistic
one even though there's a guy that
shoots bees out of a tommy gun yeah
prams bees and i just goes man and oh
the pain yeah Oh Peter you haven't
beaten three no I be playing it right
now but is this your first time you guys
getting to the pain it's yes okay it's
dumb oh there's a lot of them some of
which is good because I feel like having
a dumb metal gear solid experience is
about to happen again oh yeah so it's
not done to have that feeling it just
for a couple of months beforehand yeah
is that it's good fun and hopefully
again and again for the rest of our
gaming career indeed some time in 2015
we'll get to play the banjo
oh and then he'll stop making Metal Gear
Solid games he's been saying that since
to come back two years later with a new
one yep hooray yes